[Musique]
qui
bonjour créé son entreprise c'est
parfois innover pour cette édition du
challenge et créateurs deux finalistes
présent dans sa catégorie
installez vous confortablement c'est
parti pour la catégorie innovation
[Musique]
l'innovation c'est pour nous l'essence
même de notre projet
[Musique]
la compétition tant que les règles sont
respectées c'est une bonne chose
[Musique]
bonjour sur ses rives en jouant mais ce
choc que ce qui vous a amené à créer
cette entreprise innovante aujourd'hui
pendant les études j'avais envie de
créer une entreprise
j'ai commencé à travailler dans
l'industrie pendant sept années dans
différents secteurs sport automobile en
france en angleterre différentes
industries principalement pour des
marchés export en arrivant à la réunion
tout me suis rendu compte que j'avais
envie de faire bouger les choses et
développer un nouveau produit pour
répondre à certaines problématiques
notamment celles de trafic urbain
souhaité prendre les avantages du vélo
et les avantages de la voiture et
développer un nouveau type de véhicule
donc on a développé un triporteur cargo
caréné à l'énergie photovoltaïque qui
permet de pouvoir se déplacer livrer des
marchandises dans les centres-villes ou
déplacer des personnes sur des distances
allant jusqu'à 60 km
[Musique]
toute crise il ya une opportunité et le
chômage peut peut en être une qui permet
pouvoir créer son activité si on le
souhaite depuis depuis longtemps la
participation au challenge est une
chance ça donne un crédit complémentaire
pour un projet outre mer et et nous
permet d'avoir également une visibilité
pour pouvoir parler nous fait rêver et
essayer de changer changer notre société
progressivement
c'est l'une des étapes entreprises
innovantes qui a su allier technologie
une nouvelle technologie et
développement durable
bien nous en tant qu'expert comptable on
trouve que ce projet quand même et
viable et donc à les chances de réussite
[Musique]
bienvenue à l'usiné c'est ici qu'on a
installé les bureaux de data rocks et je
vous invite à venir voir on va pas j'ai
fait la majeure partie de mes études à
la réunion je suis parti en métropole et
en rentrant la réunion c'est un peu un
alignement des étoiles comment dire on
était aussi sur la révolution mobile
data comment on fait pour vivre par deux
ans image est derrière la chine à faire
comment on fait pour pour subsister un
autre choix c'était de dire on bénéficie
du chômage on va utiliser cet argent à
nous pour travailler sur notre produit
ce qui a fait qu'on a réussi à avoir à
maintenir une rémunération le temps de
la recherche et développement et après
au moment où on a commercialisé passé
les clients qui ont réussi à reprendre
le relais et bienvenue à datarock ce jeu
présente valérie et leurs amis sont mes
associés
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les entreprises et
collectivités génère de plus en plus de
données donc on peut c'est un logiciel
de création de tableaux de bord va
permettre de créer des tables boxe sur
la fois très design mais aussi
interactive et là où on a vraiment
apporté nous de l'innovation c'est à la
fois cette partie visuelle et interactif
mais aussi sur la partie création des
tables d'europe
on n'est pas sûr de l'innovation de
rupture on n'a pas créé quelque chose de
nouveau on est sûr plus haut sur
l'innovation d'usagé lui a donné la
possibilité de créer créer des tableaux
de bord il n'y a pas de raison pour
qu'on n'y arrive pas aussi à la réunion
donc c'est un vrai message d'espoir pour
la jeunesse réunionnaise qui est le
numérique et l'entrepreneuriat un outil
magique qu'ils ont reçues a développé un
outil indispensable pour tous managers
ou chef d'entreprise je relève aussi le
parcours de monsieur narain qui a mise à
profit une période de chômage pour
développer son projet et le mener à bien
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de la grande finale dans
l'hémicycle du département qui sera le
lauréat 2016 et la catégorie innovation
[Musique]
l'innovation c'est se poser pour se
poser il faut savoir parfois lâcher
prise il faut réfléchir et il faut se
dire que innover c'est peut-être tout
simplement repenser sa façon de
travailler et de l'ain on va gagner du
temps depuis elle a gagné d'avancé
voilà on va se poser on va écouter les
autres
on va s'écouter soi même ça aussi c'est
important est peut-être qu'on écoutant
les autres tout simplement en s'écoutant
soi même on va la trouver cette idée de
génie
peut-être ils sont là dans la zone de
délibérations alors on fait durer le
suspense
deux beaux candidat alors le prix de
l'innovation remis par la cci est
attribué à monsieur arnaud rolland jean
chéreau peut l'applaudir à redon
cherokee développe avec l'entreprise
véloce un triporteur si on développe un
triporteur cargo alimenté par l'énergie
photovoltaïque de manière à réduire
l'impact en gaz carbonique de nos
déplacements
alors cette fois ci un grand bravo aussi
parce que l'innovation a lié au
développement durable et pour ceux là
bravo de l'applaudir alors l'innovation
ça coûte cher
qu'est-ce que ça va changer de gagner ce
prix là alors on en parle est
effectivement une visibilité un soutien
financier également pour pouvoir acheter
des outillages complémentaires comme
vous le disiez l'innovation c'est
quelque chose de long qui nécessite des
financements mais on a de la chance
d'être sur un territoire où les
différents acteurs travaillent ensemble
et ça génère une synergie qui nous est
d'autant plus vis-à-vis de futurs
concurrents européens
l'internation
espérons que vous avez compris l'esprit
c'est à vous de jouer
bonne soirée et à bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]